hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today I want to talk about
genetic recombination in bacteria
bacterial cells are pretty cool because
they have the ability to take up foreign
DNA and actually incorporate it into
their own genetic profile in order to
make the protein that foreign DNA
encoded or this can give bacterial cells
extra functionality for example they
might gain new DNA that has the codes
for toxins so that codes for virulence
factors with it codes for antibiotic
resistance and the bacterial cell can
actually gain new functionality through
this way there are three different
mechanisms by which bacteria can obtain
foreign DNA these are transformations
conjugation and transduction I have
videos on all three of these mechanisms
but today let's talk about first one
transformation transformation is when a
bacterial cell takes up foreign DNA from
its environment but bringing that DNA
from its extracellular environment
across its plasma membrane the ability
of the cell to take up DNA across its
plasma membrane in this way is called
competence
many types of bacteria are naturally
competent and that they can do this
process with ease examples of such
bacteria include species of bacillus
species of Staphylococcus and CDs of
streptococcus and of course there are
well-known human pathogens within each
of these types of bacteria so now let's
look at this mechanism in a little more
detail here we have our recipient
bacterial cell
this here is its chromosomal DNA so this
is the DNA that it has had since it was
produced by replication of previous
bacterial cells but there might be
foreign DNA in this cell department I'm
going to draw this foreign DNA and read
this is DNA that is just going to be
floating through the cell's environment
it might for example be from a previous
bacterial cell that died and life and
pieces of its of this donor cell's DNA
are now just floating around the
environment the recipient bacterial cell
can actually take this DNA across its
plasma membrane so that now this DNA and
inside the cell then through the process
of recombination
the bacterial cell has its chromosomal
DNA that has recombined with this
foreign DNA so the foreign DNA has now
been integrated into the chromosome
there might be some additional foreign T
DNA that was not integrated and it's
just going to be broken down also
the bacterial DNA that was replaced by
this foreign DNA is also going to be
broken down and now we have this
genetically transformed bacterial cell
this new DNA that's taken up can give it
different functions for example there
are species of e.coli that actually
produce sugar toxin this is a toxin that
they obtained from bacteria the bacteria
tight Shigella so Shigella produces
shigga toxin the son e.coli cells can
produce it too because they're able to
go through this genetic recombination
process this DNA could also encode for
Tyrion's factors for example once it's
real it's factor might be a capsule if
the bacteria can produce a capsule
covering its outer cell wall this may
enable it to hide from a host immune
system and so this is why the process of
transformation is very important to
bacterial cells and that it can enable
them to survive in different
environments they might not have been
able to otherwise